hey youtubers it's Charlie so the
reverse-flash from the flash season 3
legends of tomorrow was explaining how
flashpoint is going to affect the
characters especially Barry Allen in
particular so this is gonna be a
breakdown to that so the really cool
thing is that Matt lizard was doing some
interviews around comic-con and
explained a little bit about the reverse
flashes context for flashpoint in the
flash season 3 so everybody knows the
reverse flash hates the out of
Barry Allen but in season 1 and season 2
they kind of brushed over as to why that
is like you know that they have history
together the flash has been battling
against him for a long time but they're
very vague about all those adventures
just to make as many references as
possible
this new flashpoint wrinkle in time is
just another reason why the reverse
flash is going to hate Barry Allen
because a person like Barry who is a
hero you know someone that people are
supposed to look up to uphold the ideas
of what heroism is you know be this
Justice League level character above
reproach but he does something selfish
and terrible like setting off this
flashpoint storyline and there are
almost no consequences to him whatsoever
everybody still loves him everybody
still thinks that he's the hero so the
reverse flash is just like god damnit
you are the villain of this story not me
so just one more reason why you bar
Thawne is gonna hate the out of
Barry Allen just throw another log on
the bonfire that is his hate for the
flash family so he also explained you
know because he's a genius where he
comes from he understands time travel in
a way that Barry does not he says that
Barry is starting to get folded into
this new timeline so he's losing
memories of the previous timeline
meaning that everything that happened
after he turned ten years old all those
memories that were created during season
one and season two
those are slowly fading away and we
start to see that happen during the
first episode like when he enters STAR
Labs in here and like you know puts his
hand on the desk that's probably what's
happening right here like STAR Labs
looks really different so normally you'd
be like oh my god what happened
Cisco's a billionaire now I don't
understand what's going on but as he
slowly gets folded into this new
flashpoint timeline he'll lose memories
of the original version of Cisco that he
grew to know so new billionaire Cisco
won't seem weird to him he'll have
always known this billionaire Cisco but
here's the thing I
think I talked about this in my last
video they said they're gonna fix
flashpoint sooner than you think that
they will but some of the changes will
stick so I think what's gonna end up
happening is Asbury will lose some
memories of the previous timeline but
for the most part he will remember all
the craziness that happened during
season two so I think what the TV show
is doing is it's finding a way to change
the personalities of all the characters
without losing the memories of what
happened during season two like think
about the arc that Caitlin was on think
about all that she suffered and how she
grew from that if they were to take
flashpoint straight up it would
completely invalidate everything that
happened to her during season two it
would have meant nothing so I think
that's what they're stopping short of
they're giving you a new Caitlin that's
full of all kinds of potential maybe
she'll become a version of killer frost
maybe she won't they'll give you all
these other new versions of characters
in a really fun way without completely
dumping on what happened during season
two so before Barry completely forgets
everything that happened during season
two I think that's when flashpoint will
be fixed so my earlier prediction is is
that's gonna happen before the
mid-season finale it could totally
happen even faster than that but keep in
mind that the big four night crossover
is gonna happen around Episode eight so
whatever they're gonna do it's probably
gonna happen before the four night
crossover because there is a big
question as to like how flashpoint
affects Barry going to the other Earth's
because if he forgets about going to
Cara's earth then he won't know who Carr
is when she comes back during the four
night crossover so what they'll probably
end up doing is fixing flashpoint right
before the big four night crossover so
let me know in the comments just because
that you know they don't want to
completely invalidate what happened
during season one and two which episode
do you think that they're gonna fix
flashpoint in and do you think that
Barry will permanently forget anything
that happened during season one and two
I think part of the curse of the hero is
is that you remember all the bad stuff
that happened like there's a lot of good
stuff that happened during season one
and two that it would really suck if he
forgot it but there's also a lot of
terrible stuff too so it's kind of a
blessing for some characters like Cisco
might not remember being murdered by the
reverse-flash and cold blood that would
definitely be a blessing for him but it
was a big part of his arc so just
remains to be seen what gets forgotten
in what they carry forward but I think
that all the stuff that's like really
critical to their emotional
in their character development the
writers will keep those memories
somewhere inside them at least some of
the characters will remember what
happened so if you're wondering what's
going on on the set of the flash like
what they're filming right now it seems
like eobard thawne has already gone to
legends of tomorrow he started filming
scenes with them so I'm guessing he's
escaped from Barry's basement I think
around Comic Con they were getting ready
to film episode three of the flash so
they're probably on Episode four by now
if they're not already shutting that
down so what's probably gonna happen is
is because they just started re airing
episodes of Supergirl on Monday nights
on the CW like the CW is getting
Supergirl so there's all these episodes
that they have to air that we're on CBS
originally so they're probably going to
drop a Supergirl season 2 trailer next
and then they'll probably start dropping
more trailers for the flash in the air
on the other shows so like I just did a
Supergirl video with some footage of
Superman kind of explaining what's going
on with that as they shut that deadly
the first couple of episodes of that
down they'll post a trailer so just
expect them to drop that during an
episode of Supergirl that they're airing
so it'll probably be on a Monday
whenever it comes it'll be on a Monday
so if you didn't see my black panther
teaser video last night I said I'm
basically seeing Suicide Squad early I'm
gonna post a non-spoilery review of that
next that'll be later tonight like way
late tonight so be sure to subscribe to
get that I'll try to explain some of the
context for the timeline without giving
away spoilers but it is supposed to be
crazy so make sure you guys go see it
this weekend because I'm probably gonna
post my Easter Egg video on Friday but
before then there'll be a whole bunch
more Marvel DC stuff going on why you
guys wait for my next video you can
click here for more flash season 3 and
you can click here for my breakdown of
the Black Panther Ceasar from Comic Con
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you